you don't see the worst parts of
humanity and and not be affected not be
screwed up it's going to change the
world till the world Chang
[Music]
me I saw you last night more importantly
I saw that look in your eyes you got a
lot of anger inside
you and if you don't find a way to let
that out it's going to eat you alive and
light me an
outlet FLH made
you to
dance batt down tonight we'll bring in
150 thank
you is this your guy yeah you think you
got what it takes you place to bet and
find out are you ready for a
fight your boy just kill a cup LAPD
everyone clear the place out now what
kind of cops you got in LAPD caught with
money dope and guns these are backs just
make sure nothing comes back to
us we need to end this wasn't sure
exactly what he needed so I brought a
few options Let's Do It come
on war exist
you take a shot better
not
I I haven't seen your face around here
no I'm
[Music]
new